yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master hmm Grand Master laughttr teen
off the sheets yet you know and his
captor the Indian flag hats not not an
Indian player probably okay so cal can
exchange so some night III this is some
uncommon night III interesting
yeah if I've looks normal actually II
five-night be five though
yeah at least you want a couple of
seconds now on the clock yeah I should
have played this somewhat quicker
yeah we reached a fairly conventional
isolated point position now the Queen on
be aid is not so conventional admittedly
but otherwise it looks like fairly
normal I've got the isolated porn but
I've got good development so just cancel
prom queen Oba Diah but ok I can just
play rook e8 Bishop d7 and develop my
pieces Oh is giving me it's giving me
two bishops for the moment ok yeah I
don't know it doesn't seem too
threatening to take ok I'm now I'm not
better or anything but doesn't look down
I've mentioned time like it's too
dangerous I can easily develop and and
continue I also don't really need to be
a afraid much of the end game with the
two bishops I have a decent decent
compensation for the isolated pawn ok
I don't want a piece appearing on f5
some can maybe simplify the position
that way I'm not sure that I want that
just should be 78 and continue
yeah one one thing about this position
is okay this pawn on d5 is weak on paper
but how is he ever going to win it he's
got no peace position to to actually
attack it this is often i'm often an
issue with isolated points they they
don't look particularly strong but how
are you I'm going to take it at the end
so huh sorry sir just it's just playing
Sifl and I'm getting rid of the dice
late for now at least I can if I if I
like to and I don't really understand
the point in fact in fact oh no I cannot
do that hmm yeah it's had some strange
idea but it's not working with based on
Bishop h3 okay but let's see how to how
to play the snow it's not particularly
good anyway for white I don't think so
maybe just this one this looks fairly
easy attacking deform and provoking a
queen trade can take 95 and I don't
think he's got any big move on the
default and then I just have the two
bishops without any particular
compensation the noise young does it
have any great any great move don't
really see any
just go here you don't see any big
discovery for this piece on default the
only issue is the hanging at this one
didn't think about that at all hmm
hmm yeah I have some very simple
yeah I didn't really appreciate 95 very
stupid yeah yeah losing this is a real
shame he just gave me a pretty
substantial edge even with the bishops
and that just didn't didn't look at the
tactics correctly even this is nothing
special probably for white maybe I'm not
sure maybe I'm just blundering but I'm
on 20 seconds which is also also a
problem
I are 96 songs sometimes time morning
check yeah it's impossible to learn to
manage at the time yeah unfortunately
dad's probably lost anyway because of
the g4 weakness I just sources I mean
this this is sorry I but this is just
nonsense c4 like is simply clearly
better now I only need to avoid the
followings probably or now here here's
something better this last night just be
should be eight and black is clearly
better now I didn't think about taking a
95 and protecting f7 and that's it the
game is basically over now white will
suffer for very long time with against
two bishops and with misplaced pieces
this is actually not well placed
computers on winning advantage already
it's not so easy technically but c4s is
just just atrocious why would you move
that you simply must stay like it's good
anyway with the two bishops but it's c4
is just giving the game away basically
but I didn't simply didn't capitalize
overlooking overlooking this this trick
it's still not so terrible but of course
no comparison to to be form and I am so
down on time that I have no chance to
really make it but what's important is
that this this kind of isolated
composition is not a big issue like
black is so well developed no bad pieces
of course this is just very cool
cooperating or why would you do that I
don't know
understandable now white can can simply
can can stay and be comfortable but
cannot play for an H anymore the best is
probably something that night f5 getting
rid of one Bishop but term otherwise
blackest is very comfortable alright
thanks for watching